hi I'm Derek Muller the creator of the
veritasium YouTube channel and this is
the wired autocomplete interview
that's a weird place I'd like
websites with the feet
[Music]
who is veritasium Guy on YouTube My
approach to making YouTube videos has
always been this is about a thing an
idea a piece of Science and it's not
about me so I don't announce my name but
I'm Derek hi nice to meet you what does
veritasium mean in Latin well it's kind
of a made up word the start of the word
Veritas is Latin for truth and then
adding ium on the end makes it sound
like an element an element of Truth get
it a lot of people thought that I had
picked the name from Harry Potter
because in Harry Potter there's Veritas
serum which is a truth serum which of
course again makes sense based on the
the Latin Veritas but I haven't actually
read Harry Potter so for me this as well
as just an element of Truth what
software does veritasium use a funny
thing about me is that I only use Final
Cut Pro X so when I'm making a thumbnail
like a lot of people will go to
photoshop so when you see the text on my
thumbnails all of that I add in Final
Cut because it's just that's my home
that's the place that I know if you see
bad animations in my video I've probably
cobbled them together in Final Cut Pro
if you see good animations they were
made by someone else in a different
piece of software probably after effects
where does Derek Muller live currently
living in Los Angeles parents were South
African I was born in Australia I grew
up in Canada and now I live in LA
so I've been all over and who knows how
long we'll stay here Derek Muller accent
my accent I feel like is generally North
American I try to fit in wherever I go
so here in the states I try to basically
just sound American in the early videos
I did sound a bit Australian because I
was living in Australia and even when I
say the word Australian then I start to
sound a bit Australian so this is me
doing an Australian accent which frankly
is not that good and Australians we're
gonna cringe and they'll say oh that's a
terrible accent that's getting a little
bit kiwi isn't it what is he doing
anyway if I have a few drinks and I'm
talking to people in Australia then
normally my accent starts to shift a
little bit like an empathy thing right
when Derek Muller was young I guess at
all times before now I grew up in the
90s I want to say and I graduated high
school in 2000 that's when I was young I
am now almost 40 years old which is
crazy is Derek Muller married yes to a
beautiful wonderful wife Raquel uh who's
a planetary geologist a wonderful mother
to my three children which is amazing
veritasium had to go viral a couple
years ago I made a video about how a
video of mine went viral and immediately
after that I made a video about how that
video went viral and the answer is I
guess a couple simple things one a lot
of people wanted to click on that video
the click-through rate was good and two
people stayed watching the video once
they clicked on it in my mind the
hardest thing about YouTube is people
knowing that you even exist so that's
why having a viral video is so important
because it raises your channel up in the
consciousness of millions of people and
then they were more likely to come back
and see you again how
smart is veritasium honestly I don't
think I'm terribly smart I consider my
intelligence to be about average but I
think I work pretty hard kind of
stubborn and that I won't let Dia go and
I won't stop until I get to the bottom
of something how to contact veritasium
try me on Twitter I'm I'm pretty
terrible at all social media there is a
contact form on the website a couple
years ago someone emailed us and said
why don't you do a video about bowling I
don't know anything about bowling the
science of bowling I don't know what's
going on there but he had connections
got us into a bowling ball manufacturing
facility and I got to learn way more
about bowling than I ever thought I
would know and it was fascinating and
there was a ton of science there so I
loved it how
many subscribers does veritasium I
assume have at this point
12.7 million subscribers I'm gonna say
I'm very appreciative I never thought
that I would get to this number of
subscribers I didn't think I would reach
a million I wanted to be a creative
person but I was scared of being a
creative person and so I made YouTube
videos
from a good Channel I would say yes but
of course I'm biased one of my goals is
I want the video to be surprising I want
it to be interesting I made this video
about the speed of light and how it's
really hard to measure the speed of
light in One Direction which is a weird
thing because as a physicist going
through you think that everyone knows
the speed of light speed of light in one
direction should be well known but the
truth is whenever we've measured it
we've always measured it in two
directions not One Direction because
measuring One Direction's really hard
videos like that lead people to question
hang on is this legit my answer is yes I
had a physics Professor from UCLA that
made ten thousand dollars that one of my
videos was wrong I was excited about
that bet because it gave me the
opportunity to explore the ideas and I
feel like maybe I hadn't done a good
enough job in the first video that bet
gave me a chance to delve deeper and
explain it better than I did the first
time I don't always get it right the
first time but I'm always passionate
about getting it right is veritasium
wrong about electricity City I don't
think I'm wrong about electricity and I
think if you watch all of the
commentaries that say like veritasium is
wrong in their headline if you actually
watch the video you find inside the
video they're like actually you know
technically he says everything he says
is right but they want to use that as as
click bait I guess the way electricity
works is counter-intuitive I feel like I
explained it as well as anyone can if
you disagree with me then make your own
video
because I would like to see that is
veritasium a real Element no no it is
not it would be really cool if one day
veritasium was a real element uh but but
no is veritasium a physicist yes I
studied engineering physics as my
undergraduate degree at Queen's
University in Canada then I moved to
Australia and I was going to go to film
school so I need to do something here in
Australia while I'm getting ready to go
to film school and I decided to enroll
in a PhD so I had to do graduate level
physics courses in order to get the PHD
but I was trying to merge my passions in
science and film and they had a physics
education research group and I pitched
them on the idea of doing a PhD on how
to make videos that would teach physics
effectively so my PhD in physics is
technically about how do you make a film
and then you show that film to students
and what elements can you put in those
films that make them more educational
veritasium best videos I do love this
video that I made years ago the most
common cognitive bias do you have it and
it's about confirmation bias which is I
think something a lot of us suffer from
obviously the most viewed video is this
one shade balls on the LA Reservoir
because it's just such a weird thing to
see 96 million black balls spread across
a lake type thing super weird veritasium
first video the first real veritasium
video I would say was one about the
atomic hypothesis Richard Feynman asked
the question what if all of scientific
knowledge was wiped out and we could
only leave one sentence to the people
who came after what one sentence would
carry the most information on the path
to recovering all the scientific
knowledge and for Feynman it was the
atomic hypothesis the idea that
everything in our universe is made up of
atoms and they attract each other when
they're far apart but kind of repel if
they get too close and that is about as
good as you could do in a single
sentence on the path to rediscovering
all of knowledge veritasium clickbait
hopefully this isn't people accusing me
of making clickbait but I do have a
video about clickbait I called it the
unreasonable effectiveness of clickbait
and in that video I reflect on my own
terrible history with trying to title
and thumbnail my own videos so my goal
with the title and thumbnail is always
to help people understand what is this
video actually about and often the most
technical or clear or specific like
scientifically accurate way to represent
that is not the way that people will
understand what that video is really
about and this is a shift that I've only
feel like I've realized in the last few
years and even now we are really really
bad at it and I want to apologize to all
the people out there because sometimes I
launch a video with a certain title and
thumbnail people don't know what we're
talking about and we switch it to a
different title and thumbnail and people
feel like we're trying to manipulate
them I am just trying to give the video
the clearest possible title and
thumbnail that really communicate what
this video is about veritasium our
greatest delusion for me this is one of
my most personal videos it's the idea
that we think in some way that we all
ask forever that's a good delusion to
have I guess when you're living is like
not to be thinking about your mortality
all the time and I think it's how most
of us live but I do think it's important
to recognize from time to time that we
don't have that permanence having that
perspective hopefully allows you to
focus on on the really really important
things in life so I hope when people
watch that video that's maybe a feeling
that they get out of it go for things
that are really meaningful and spend
their time on those things as opposed to
the the frivolous stuff that we fill our
lives with
how much does Derek Muller make way more
than I ever thought I would make it's
always kind of impossible to know what a
YouTuber makes because you don't know
where those views are coming from and
the rates are just so variable and we
have no way of checking on YouTube to
say like okay is that really where this
is coming from we just take their word
for it they're like hey this is this is
what you get and you're like I guess
it's more than I made doing regular jobs
so I'm happy with it Derek Muller
PhD thesis I wrote a PhD thesis which is
about 300 Pages I'm going to put a link
to the thesis from my website anyone who
wants to read my PhD you're more than
welcome to I think it's very readable
because it's a PhD on how to make films
uh to teach physics Derek Muller
twisting the Dragon's Tail this is not
something I like to do for fun in my
spare time it is part of the name of a
documentary that I did and it goes
through the whole history of
radioactivity discovering how we get
energy from rocks and radiation what can
be used for development of the bomb all
that sort of stuff and the reason why
the term twisting the dragon's tail is
there is because I think some of the
scientists at Los Alamos who were
working on the atomic bomb talked about
tickling the Dragon's Tail where they
were trying to find the critical mass
the amount of this radioactive matter
that you would need to cause a fission
chain reactions you're experimenting
with the very edge of causing a gigantic
explosion
thank you a wired audience for hanging
out with me if you want to see more of
what I do go check out veritasium
they didn't even tell me to do that I
just did a Shameless plug for my channel
because I'm a YouTuber it is in my blood
now it is in My DNA to say you know what
go spell veritasium up in the search bar